it's always a that's a very important
question because you have to learn to
love whatever you do like in the
failures as much as the successes
because they'll probably be a lot more
failures and successes and so that's a
very important lesson to learn early on
and I learned it early in my career
because my PhD really got off to a
pretty poor start and so there's a long
period of time where I had to say is
this worth it and many of my friends are
just sort of saying like you you know
you're already accepted into Medical
School why do you even need this and I
think I was just really like it's the
the puzzle that I was sort of trying to
figure out was just it compelling enough
to me that I kept going with it so I
think in science you have to be very
patient you have to enjoy like the the
process and it's nice to think about
where the process will take you but it's
important to enjoy like each aspect of
the process itself and so I think that
we're lucky because we're in a time
right now that there are so many tools
available that there are many
discoveries being made so you know
there's just many opportunities to
advance the field and it's coming from
all directions so that's a lucky time
but obviously there will be droughts
where we figured we've kind of you know
tapped the genome to its full potential
and looking for the next thing and the
difficulties with each aspect of you
know changing paradigms so though there
will be periods I've already you know
experienced some maybe not like the
biggest I could experience but it
definitely experienced long periods of
failed work and I just I still enjoy it
I just enjoy the day-to-day and that's
important I love teaching
yeah that's one of the reasons why I
didn't look at I looked at being on an
undergraduate campus because I really
enjoy teaching I think it's I think it's
wonderful and you're very lucky to be
with such I mean all students are really
exciting but it's really lucky to be
with such motivated students it's you
know it's an easy job so it's it's
really up to you you know if the
students are engaged it's something you
have to think about you know how do you
engage them